>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Frederick Augustyn: Welcome to
today's presentation by Valerie Frey
on Preserving Family Recipes.
My name is Fred Augustyn and I
work as a Reference Librarian
on a split assignment in
the Manuscript Division,
and also I'm a Past President,
still in this century,
but quite a few years ago, of the
Library of Congress Cooking Club,
and a continuing member of it.
Those of -- both of
the organizations
that are sponsoring this program.
We are being videotaped
and by asking a question you're
hereby giving your permission
to have your voice recorded
and, depending on the angle
of the camera, your
image as well recorded.
And I ask you to turn off
any electronic devices
that might possibly
interfere with the recording.
And I'm going to introduce
Laura Kells who is an Archivist
in the Manuscript Division.
>> Laura Kells: Hi.
Introducing lots of
introductions here.
But anyway, I just want to -- I'm
so pleased to have the opportunity
to introduce Valerie Frey who has
returned to the Library of Congress
to speak to us about her book,
Preserving Family Recipes,
How to Save and Celebrate
Your Food Traditions .
I first met Valerie in 1999
when she was a Junior Fellow
in the Manuscript Division.
She worked with me on processing
the Herbert Philbrick papers
that summer.
And while she was here at LC she
also participated in the Library
of Congress Bicentennial
Cookbook Project.
By the time she was a Junior Fellow
Valerie had already received a
Master's Degree in Art Education
from the University of Georgia
and had just completed a Master's
Degree in Information Science
with a concentration in
Historical Research in Archives
from the University of
Tennessee in Knoxville.
I think the thing I remember
about Valerie is right
after she left she went to Nepal.
I think that was the
best [inaudible] before,
and she sent us a postcard
of Mount Everest [laughter].
But after she returned she
began her professional career.
She was a Manuscript Archivist
in the Georgia Historical Society
in Savannah, an Archivist of
the Savannah Jewish Archives.
Then she became the Education
Coordinator of the Georgia Archives.
Valerie is currently a writer and
consultant whose projects focus
on genealogy, local
history, storytelling,
material culture folklife, and home
life, both modern and historic.
Valerie kept in touch with me
over the years and she returned
to the Library, I think
it was about 2008,
to do some research
for this book here.
Valerie's interests and
experience are quite evident
in Preserving Family Recipes .
She looks at recipes
as primary documents.
Her book is a mix of personal
stories and fact, tips and guidance
for books -- for people
interested in gathering, adjusting,
and preserving their family
recipes, and collecting
and documenting family
food traditions.
But I'll let her elaborate.
So please welcome Valerie Frey.
[ Applause ]
>> Valerie Frey: It's really
a pleasure to be here.
Starting off at the largest library
in the world when you're right
of library school is daunting.
But everybody was so welcoming
here and the things that I learned
as a Junior Fellow were amazing.
So I've been pushing lots of bright
new shiny faces to come this way
and hope that you'll get some.
So this books was a long labor of
love and it started off with --
I worked as Education
Coordinator at the Georgia Archives
and I was pretty sure
going into the job
that first day what the
job was going to entail.
But I think as a lot of us know,
sometimes you have to change
when you realize what the
job really needs most.
I would go into the
classrooms, mostly Atlanta,
but all over the state of Georgia,
and bringing primary documents,
helping them to learn how
to do historic research.
And there was enough resistance
that one day I finally asked,
how many people here like history?
And only two kids raised their hand.
And right there my whole job
shifted of it's not okay, you know,
for kids to think that history is
boring or irrelevant to their lives.
They're not going to
be good citizens.
They're not going to have
kind of the grounding roots.
This is a photography of
my grandparents and my dad.
My dad was around three years old.
They lived in -- about an hour
south of Little Rock, Arkansas.
And they were my memory-keepers.
They were the ones that -- they
were always telling me stories
about the way life was for
them, but also in the past.
Both sides of that family, my
grandmother and grandfather,
they arrived long before
the Civil War.
And told me stories and shared
recipes and shared things
so that I grew up caring
about history.
And when I found that these
kids across schools didn't care
about history, that was
the best way I knew how,
was to start in with stories
and to also find photographs
of kids their age a century ago,
and sort of start in that direction.
And one of the things -- I had
my great-great-grandmother's
teacake recipe.
She was born in 1830, died in 1900,
would have cooked on
a wood-burning stove.
And so I would make these
teacakes and then bring them in.
And the kids would taste them.
We would talk about how they were
alike and different than Oreos.
How they would have been cooked.
And from there I started
getting their attention.
And I realized that foodways was
one of the best ways to get an in,
to get -- everybody eats,
everybody loves food.
And so from there on out I
started including information
about preserving recipes in my adult
programs that I did on genealogy
and oral history and
those sorts of things.
And it really struck a nerve.
I think a lot of people
are interested
in preserving it but don't know how.
So I started interviewing people
who had done family cookbooks.
One of the things I learned right
off the bat is people assume
that once you have some kind
of a recipe you're done.
And it's really not true.
Sometimes they don't work the
way you had hoped they were
or that you'd make it and
it doesn't taste anything
like grandma's apple pie.
So what do you do from there?
So I did a lot of interviews
to sort of figure
out what you do from there.
Let's see.
The value in a recipe -- here's
some cookbooks from my shelf.
And there are a lot of
buzzwords on the spine labels
about whether it's simple
or natural or diet or quick.
There's a lot of reasons
we reach for a recipe.
And that's -- you know, for what
you're going to cook tonight
or tomorrow or next week.
But when you look at family recipes,
I'm hoping that I can expand
your horizons to look at them
in a little bit different way and
with a little bit different values.
There's a nutritional value to food.
Of course we want it to be
something that we want to eat.
There is definitely a sensual value.
And it's not just the
way things taste.
It's that smell.
I have some favorite autumn recipes
that almost always include molasses
and spices, because then the
whole house smells divine.
But just -- I get into biscuits and
when you do biscuits and you pour
that chilly buttermilk in the
soft flour and you start working
with your hands, there's a
sensual value to cooking for sure.
And there's also an emotional value.
This is my son, Eli.
He was, I think, four
in the picture.
And he's seven now.
He's off at the Air and Space Museum
with my permission [laughter].
My husband was going to come
today and I was like, no,
you sat through this presentation.
Go ahead, go.
Pictured here is my
mom's chess tarts.
She would make these
in Athens, Georgia,
where we lived every Thanksgiving.
And she'd pack them in shirt
boxes and carry them to Arkansas
where we always had Thanksgiving.
And since -- my parents died
when I was in my early 20s.
And Thanksgiving, the first
Thanksgiving was pretty hard.
From then on out, you know, turkey
tastes pretty much the same.
My mom used a boxed stuffing
mix, so that was easy.
But what it boiled down to for
this holiday is this is the taste
of Thanksgiving for me.
And they didn't work
right off the bat.
Thank goodness my mother
wrote in her cookbooks.
Please write in your
cookbooks even though if --
you know, as a Librarian I feel
weird telling people to write
in a book, but please
write in your cookbooks
because that's an information
trail for the people behind you.
But I still had trouble.
They tasted good.
People who didn't grow up
with them, they ate them up.
But my brother and I would
always kind of look at each other
and shake our heads the few
times I tried to make them.
And then this year, when
my -- maybe it was my son,
maybe he was the magic mojo,
the grandson that she --
my mother never got to meet.
But I took my time and one of
the things I thought about is --
I measure the way the -- Betty
Crocker tells you to measure flour
where you dump the flour
in and level it off.
If you use the scoop, you use it
like a scoop like my mom always did,
you can pack the flour and you
end up with too much flour.
But I thought, well, that
was the way she did it.
And when I tried it that way --
I baked them, I handed one
to my brother, he took a bite
and closed his eyes, and then
his head snapped up and he said,
this is a little round time machine.
There's something to that.
When you take a bit of something
that somebody has made for you
with love, it means a lot.
And so it's something I
make every Thanksgiving now.
So there's definitely an
emotional value with food that kind
of carries you back to
other times and places.
What I'd like to talk
a little bit more
about today is the
historic value of recipes.
And we're going to zip through
some recipes and look at them
for their historic value.
In recipes you will
find family history,
culinary history, and
social history.
And I love social history.
I know some many genealogists
that --
when I worked at a public
reference desk they go leaping right
for the dates and the
-- confirming the names,
and without some social
history, and especially
when you go far enough back that
you don't know real life stories
about those people, the social
history helps you know what life was
like for your ancestors
and makes them come alive.
And food history is
fantastic for that.
So let's take a little foray into
social history around a recipe.
Actually, let me back
up a little bit.
So my parents got married in 1962.
It was a small church wedding.
My dad was from rural Arkansas.
My mom was from right
along the Columbia River
in Oregon, not far from Portland.
And he had gone to school up there.
They met, fell in love.
And at that time, travel
was pretty expensive.
They were both poor students.
And so they got married.
But my grandparents --
my grandmother was sick and wasn't
able to come to the wedding.
She had -- was chronically
ill at that time.
So they married in September.
And in December the gift that all
the parents gave was train tickets
so they could go to Arkansas and
meet his family for the first time.
So my mother arrives at night.
And the next morning there's this
huge dinner for the whole family.
My dad was the only child,
but my grandpa was one of 14
and my grandma was one of four,
so the house was just jam-packed
with all these aunts and uncles
and cousins and everything else.
And my grandpa made -- he
was the cook in the family
and he made his signature stew.
And when he handed her a bowl, this
is sort of what it looked like.
This is a batch -- I
took a photo in 1991.
And if you'll notice that there's
sort of this strange object
in the middle of the pot.
To help you picture that,
that's a skull [laughter].
Nobody thought to tell her
that it was squirrel soup,
squirrel mulligan, and
that was his specialty.
And it was -- for rural Arkansas,
squirrel was quite
common at that time.
I think a lot of people
still eat squirrel and --
>> Yuck.
>> Laura Kells: But it was not
exactly what she was expecting
when she reached for that bowl.
So it was this hilarious story
in our family is, you know,
here you're the new bride
going thaaanks [laughter].
After my parents died
in my early 20s,
I started realizing
that my links were gone.
My grandparents were all still
alive but my parents were gone.
And all these stories
that my parents knew --
I could no longer ask them.
But there was this
older generation to ask.
And so ask I did.
I recorded stories.
I took lots of photographs.
And I asked about the recipes.
And this was one of the things
that I asked my grandfather for.
And he just kind of laughed.
He said there is no recipe.
Oh, here's another picture
of the skull just to --
you know, you can see its fangs
-- his little teeth [laughter].
So I asked my grandpa
for the recipe.
And he was wonderful.
He took a stab at writing it down.
But when I read through
the recipe --
he was actually a highly
intelligent man,
but he had a eighth-grade
education, and the recipe
that I got reflected his grammar
and knowledge of spelling.
But that was easy to sort out.
What was not easy to sort out was --
there was so much know-how he
didn't even realize he knew.
He didn't tell me how much
liquid to put in the pot.
He didn't tell me -- real,
the secret to how good it tasted
was his home-grown vegetables
and how he prepared
those and canned those.
So I ended up learning how to
interview him for more information,
how to interview other cooks
that did squirrel mulligan
for more information, and then
how to search through cookbooks
from the time period when he
developed this recipe to learn more.
So what I ended up learning from the
process was that, just like primary
and secondary sources are
great when you're a genealogist
and you're trying to learn
more about your family history,
it also works for the recipes.
There are so many cookbooks
now that are available.
It used to be, I think, you know,
30 years ago if you needed old
cookbooks you would have to track
down a reputable bookseller and
have them do searches for you.
Well, now in the days of the Web,
there's so many of the cookbooks
that have been digitized.
And the Library of
Congress has digitized some.
There are a lot of sources for that.
They're listed in the book.
But so if you need a
help on that it's there.
And so to compare a recipe, if
you are missing out on, you know,
how long do I cook this, how
much liquid do I put in the pot,
if you compare it with other
squirrel mulligan or soup recipes
or like my grandpa
actually adapted the recipe
for chicken, thank goodness.
So I was able to look at a
lot of chicken soup recipes
to figure out what he did.
And then the secondary sources --
food history has just exploded
in the last couple of decades
and they're wonderful sources.
And I found a lot of them
that mentioned squirrel.
Thomas Jefferson --
Damon Lee Fowler worked
with the early Monticello recipes,,
and Thomas Jefferson had
recipes for squirrel.
There's so many good
books that I read through.
Mark Kurlansky wrote Food
From a Younger Land ,
and I learned that the
squirrel mulligan recipe
that was my grandfather's
-- that was a regional dish,
fairly close in range to
where my grandparents lived.
And that it started in the
Golden Age of Railroading.
The hobos would sort of do
these communal one-pot dishes.
And it's a cousin to
burgoo and booya
and Brunswick stew
and some other things.
So by understanding
this recipe in context,
the primary documents help
me sort of narrow down when
and where it came from, but also
how to cook it successfully.
And those secondary sources really
help me to know how my family fit
into this culinary history and
social history of the United States.
So it's fascinating that
recipes can do this for us.
Every single recipe
you have has a story.
Some of them may be very boring.
I think the most boring recipe
story in the world is --
I clipped this out of
the newspaper last week
and I haven't made
it yet [laughter].
But for so many other recipes
that we have in our boxes
and our card files, there's
a lot of more there to it.
The story of a recipe is where
it came from if you know that.
Who used it.
How it was served.
You know, the squirrel
mulligan story.
You know, I love this serving
it to the new daughter-in-law.
How it changed over time.
We're going to talk more
about that in a second.
Stories or tales connected to it.
And then again how it fits
into all that food history.
So think about that as you
go through the recipes.
I think a lot of us flip
through family recipes with, no,
I wouldn't want to make that.
No, I wouldn't want to eat that.
That's how we look at them.
But if you look at them as what can
this recipe tell me about the people
who came before me or about the
people that I share my table with,
then they start to have
a new historic value.
Let me tell you another recipe story
that will tell you a little
bit more about recipes here.
This is me back in 2006.
So I got engaged.
And the next year I got married.
If you'll notice the groom has
an Air Force officer's uniform.
What that adds up to very
quickly is moving boxes.
So we got married.
He deployed the next month.
A couple of months
later he came back.
And then in the middle of
the summer, when I had a baby
on the way, he announces that
we're moving to California.
And I had lived in Washington,
D.C. those three months,
but otherwise I had always lived
within a four-hour
driving distance of home.
So suddenly I packed up
everything I owned, left everybody
that I knew except for my
husband, and headed cross-country.
And so really it was
sort of a recipe
for home sickness is what it was.
This is a picture -- we ate at
Chez Panisse, if you all know
that famous restaurant in Berkeley.
We ate there on our first
wedding anniversary.
And then the next month
little guy popped up here.
And I was working on this
book at the same time.
And what I realized is
the home sickness was
so thick you could almost
grab it out of the air
and squeeze the juice out of it.
I missed my mom and dad.
Especially though when
you're pregnant, you know,
you just really want your mom there.
I missed my brother.
I missed all that familiarity.
The first holidays came --
Thanksgiving and Christmas and none
of the food tasted right.
I realized one afternoon,
through kind of a veil of tears,
that what I really wanted
to help make things right
was my mom's spaghetti.
Now, if you're of an Italian
descent I would like you
to just cover your eyes
please and not look at this
because [laughter] this is in
no way high-brow spaghetti.
But I think that's important because
I think a lot of times the foods
that are dear to us, they aren't
always highfaluting recipes.
And I think that's fine.
I think when it comes
to family recipes
that we can just take our snobbery
and kind of put it to the side
for a little while and
enjoy what we enjoy.
So there in my California kitchen
I called my brother several times.
We both had made the
spaghetti with my mom.
It wasn't written down anywhere.
And this is what we figured out.
And when I made it this way
it tasted, it tasted right.
But I noticed that my mom -- I
had inherited my mom's skillet,
but we had one of those
glass cooktops
and you're not allowed
to put cast-iron on it.
So I had to substitute
my cast-iron skillet.
And then I realized my mom,
she would buy these tubes
of ground beef whenever they went
on sale, and she would slice them
and put them in the freezer.
And, as a kid, you knew it was
spaghetti night because you'd come
from breakfast and
there'd be this lump
of beef thawing beside the sink.
Well, I was about to leave
the lump of beef by the side
of the sink all day the way my mom
did, so I thawed it in a microwave
which didn't exist when
this recipe came about.
So I'm going to kind of hurry
through this because this isn't --
this is something I'd like you
to just get the gist of,
not absorb completely.
But when I started working with
the recipe further I started
to realize that, hey, I'm living in
Berkeley, California, foodieville.
I'm going to go for the fresh
and, hey, why not grass-fed bison?
Why not free-range turkey?
And as I worked my
way through I started
to realize I was making
all kinds of substitutions
that my mother didn't
have those choices.
That Athens, Georgia, it
was a fairly small town
when I was growing up, and the
grocery stores were pathetic.
There wasn't much choice there.
It was like yellow onion
or white onion basically.
But, hey, if you want to see a
happy Georgia girl in Berkeley,
California, who's pregnant
and homesick,
try finding a Vidalia
onion from Georgia.
I about did a happy dance
in the grocery store.
One of the things my
pediatrician told me is don't eat
out of cans while you're pregnant,
which was really a scary thought
to me that, you know, the lining of
the can would have BPA or whatever.
So I made sure to track down --
they have the little sealed cartons.
And then I started, hey, might
as well just use fresh tomatoes,
and organic and heirloom.
And I bought the herbs and
put them on the back porch.
They have the new pastas
that are the high fiber
and they have the lentil flour,
so they've got the protein
and by the time my son was, you
know, came along and was old enough
to eat, you know, the
thought of this vermicelli
that we always twirled at the family
dinner table, that was not going
to fly with an 18-month-old.
So, you know, you do the little
bowties so they can pick them up.
My mom always put a lump
of shortening in the water
to keep it from boiling over.
And, you know, then we had the whole
trans-free fat thing and then I read
that you're not even supposed
to put anything in the water
because then the pasta
doesn't stick.
And so I think you can see what's
going to happen with this recipe
that after a while we wonder is
it even mom's spaghetti anymore?
There's all these changes.
But it's fascinating when you stop
to look at why all these changes.
It's because technology changed.
You know, the glass cooktop
and the microwave oven
and the nonstick cookware.
The ingredient availability is --
it really shows where our culture
has gone in the last 25 years
that there's all these
fancy things available.
The things we know about health
and the decisions now that --
I don't think my mom ever made
any decision of to put something
in the grocery cart depending on
how it would affect the environment.
And I do. I care.
She would have cared, too.
But it wasn't, you know,
it wasn't an issue then.
How much time we have available.
Our needs and preferences.
So all those things are part
of the story of that recipe.
And, unfortunately, I think
that halts a lot of people
because they think, well, I
don't do it the way my mom did,
so I don't even know which
is the real family recipe.
Well, the answer is they're
both the real family recipe.
And the changes between them, if you
take the time to sort of explain,
is a fascinating trail
for future generations
to read about how life changed.
I mean, this was just,
you know, one generation.
So let's look at some
other recipes to kind
of see what historical
trails are inside them.
This is -- I've got these written
down so I know sometimes
it can be hard to see.
So if you wouldn't mind
passing those along.
>> Sure, yeah.
>> Valerie Frey: This is a recipe
for boiled Indian Meal Pudding.
Mix one quart of cornmeal
with three quarts of milk.
Take care it be not lumpy.
Add three eggs and
a gill of molasses.
It must be put on at
sunrise to eat at 3 o'clock.
The great art in this pudding
is tying the bag properly,
as the meal swells very much.
Now the first time I read this
recipe my only thought was, huh?
I had no idea what it
was even talking about.
Anybody want to hazard a guess
of what time period this
recipe may have come from?
Yeah. This one's pretty old.
This is a hearth recipe.
This one came from The
Virginia Housewife, 1824 .
Is it in standard receipt format
according to what you have seen?
That's one of the first clues, is
a lot of times once you get past
about 1900 it was the reformers.
Everybody credits Fannie Farmer,
but it wasn't just Fannie Farmer.
It was Eliza Acton and a
bunch of other women reformers
that were pushing for more clarity
in recipes, a list of ingredients
that would be moved through
in chronological order.
But that didn't exist here.
Are the ingredients
common or easy to get?
>> Easy.
>> Valerie Frey: They're
pretty common.
So it's -- this -- I mean
it's basically just cornmeal
and milk and molasses.
So it would have been
things that, in the South,
they would have had on the farm.
So it's not a fancy
recipe by any means.
Do you think it was a everyday
recipe or a special occasion recipe?
Is it fancy?
Can you tell?
I know it was hard
to tell sometimes.
Some of these questions
you can ask yourself
and you can't maybe not come
up with a clear conclusion
until you've read some more sources.
This is actually a pretty every --
would have been used for
an everyday occasion.
This is yesteryear's crockpot.
If it's hog-killing
time and the lady
of the house has her hands full,
you know, she doesn't have time
to cook a full meal and, you
know, help scald the hog.
So this would have been put on
-- I made my little example here.
If you do a image search
on the Web for pudding bag,
you will see something
that looks more elegant
than what I was able to do.
This is one of those things, you
know, where -- there's Pinterest.
You see an idea and then
when you actually do it,
it's much harder than it looks.
This is one of those kind of things.
But they would have
put the ingredients --
the milk and the eggs
and the molasses would have been
put inside fabric like this.
Sometimes it was buttered and
floured, and sometimes it wasn't.
And it was gathered
and tied with twine.
And then this whole thing
would have been set in a pot
of boiling water over the hearth.
And so the lady of the house would
have had to just come in once
or twice just to bank the fire,
make sure that it was
bubbling along nicely,
and then would have been
able to lift this out.
And it would have been solid by
then and she would slice it up
and everybody would
have had a slice.
But one of the things that
they're eluding to, the trouble.
If you tie it too tight
then the cornmeal's pulls
in liquid from the outside.
It would burst it.
So you come in from the field hungry
and what you have is a burst bag
and everything is floating
around in water
and you can't even just put the
kids in the car and go to McDonalds
because it doesn't exist yet.
And a gill, by the way, was
four ounces or a half cup.
So, again, that's one of the clues
to this recipe that it's older,
is it -- there's an
unusual measurement there.
Let's jump a little bit up in time.
Anybody want to hazard a guess for
eggless, milkless, butterless cake?
>> World War II I'd say.
>> Valerie Frey: That -- as --
I always thought it
was just World War II.
It's actually -- this recipe
was a World War I recipe
which was a surprise for me.
But it had a big resurgence
during the Great Depression
and during World War II.
When you didn't have to
use eggs, milk, and butter,
you saved ration coupons and
also saved expensive ingredients.
So is it in standard recipe format?
It is. We've reached that,
that period where that's
becoming more common.
Are they ingredients that you
could have gotten off the farm?
>> No.
>> Valerie Frey: Not anymore.
We're reaching that age.
Probably 20 or 30 years before,
some of these ingredients would have
been really rare and hard to get.
And this would have been a super
fancy item to make for company.
But we've reached the age
where nutmeg and cinnamon,
they were coming from a long
way away around the world,
but they were becoming more common.
You could get them in the, you
know, the grocery store or whatever.
No, they wouldn't have
had a grocery, but a --
I want to say trading post,
but that's not the right word.
Just your general store
would have had these items.
Another clue if you're -- you
know, if you found this recipe
in a family recipe trove and
you didn't have any indication
of where it came from, the
seeded raisins is one indication.
Older recipes would tell you to
use the seeded raisins or seedless.
Seedless came later.
And seeded raisins -- I actually
found a recipe not long ago
to tell you if -- let's
see, it was a 1909 cookbook
that told how you did that.
And you soaked the raisins and then
with a knife you would slit each
raisin and pick out the seeds.
So my father's -- it's
also a recipe you only make
for people you like [laughter].
It would have been a lot of work.
And then the citron is
an ingredient that --
it was very popular in
cookbooks in the 1800s.
And it's a citrus fruit, but you
use the rind instead of the pulp.
And now we see it really only once
a year, and about this time of year
when all the fruitcake
materials pop up.
You find it in little tubs now and
it's already been candied for you.
And that's really the only
time we see citron anymore.
Ingredients come and go in terms
of popularity just like, you know,
recipes come and go or, you know,
the fondue pot that was so popular
in the '70s, you know,
went the way of the dodo.
But now it's had a resurgence.
I think a lot of people
are doing fondue again.
All right.
We'll jump up one more time.
Anybody want to guess where
Sock It to Me Cake, what decade
or so that might have been from?
>> The [inaudible].
>> Valerie Frey: Yeah.
That's Laugh-In in the 1960s
had that as their catch-phrase.
It was fascinating.
When I searched for Sock It
to me Cake the first time,
I didn't find much about it.
And then last week I talked to
the Southern Festival of Books,
and I met Anne Bern who's -- she's
the Cake Doctor who does the books
where you work on the cake mixes.
She has a new book
called, American Cakes .
so if you love food history,
this is a beautiful book.
And she really tested
those recipes so they're --
and she had a selection
of cakes for us to try,
so I know that they're good.
But she has a little sidebar
about Sock It to Me Cake.
And I discovered that it started
in Texas and kind of circulated
through Oklahoma, so the fact that
my Arkansas grandmother had it
in her cookbook makes sense, how
very close they are geographically.
But I did find out that
later on Duncan Hines put it
on one of their cake mix boxes.
But the recipe's a little different.
And I brought that for you --
>> [Inaudible] much the same though.
I used to make the Sock It to Me --
>> Valerie Frey: Did you [laughter]?
I printed it up for you here.
A lot of times people ask me sort
of what my ideal format
would be for recipes.
So I did the Sock It to Me
Cake that way so you could see
where I've done, you know,
put it in the standard format
with the ingredients listed first,
because the way my
grandmother had it here --
I mean, that's the whole recipe,
so people have always asked
me, wait, what do you do?
So I looked it up.
I looked through all the -- and
came up with directions for it.
I love doing them in steps --
one, two, three, four, five,
so if I get interrupted I
remember what step to go back to.
I always put cooking
notes and history notes.
And then, if I can, I'll put a
little image of the original recipe
so that the handwriting's there.
And here's a picture of my grandma.
So I'll have that for you today
as sort of a template on things.
So this one is no longer in
your standard recipe format,
but is it unusual ingredients?
Not very common for the 1960s.
Any grocery store, even a
little country grocery store
like my grandma had,
would have worked.
Is it fancy?
Not particularly.
You know, I could see making
it for when company comes
but it would have been very easy
and quick and cheap to make.
It is very mid-century.
You know, we looked at that Eggless,
Milkless, Butterless Cake recipe
that would have been scratch and
you'd have done the whole thing.
Well, by the time you get to
the middle of the 20th century,
you know, get the lady out of the
kitchen, make things quick and easy,
just doctor up a cake mix.
That's a lot of the recipes
that I was left with,
are those kind of recipes.
And it's not the way I cook anymore.
So when I've made Sock It to Me Cake
I have a favorite yellow cake recipe
that's from scratch, and
then I make that and go
on with the rest of it from there.
So with these old family recipes
you can go those directions.
If it's fancy, you can,
you know, swap a --
instead of mush make
your own mushroom sauce,
you can put in a can
of mushroom soup.
Or you can go the other
direction and go fresh with it.
The main thing is to play with it
and enjoy it and have fun with it.
So let's talk -- I'm going to
switch gears on you a little bit
and just talk about some
of the things that I notice
when people worked
with family recipes,
the things that I heard
over and over again.
That they would be
excited about them
but then they wouldn't
end up working with them.
Well, why?
What can we do to get you past that?
One of the things I heard a lot is
that the old recipes are out of date
and nobody wants them anymore.
And, as we just talked about,
please play with those recipes.
If you are a from-scratch person,
and it has a cake mix,
you can get around that.
You would record the original in
its original format so that any,
anybody else wants to
play with that recipe,
they can go back to the original.
But make your own version.
I type all mine into the
computer and so I just hit Save As
and then I go to town using other
cookbooks, using other recipes
for ideas, and testing it,
tweaking it until it's something
that really fits my
needs and my purposes.
I lighten up a lot of things.
I go fresh with a lot of things.
But they're still those
original recipes.
Another thing I've heard is that,
you know, how many great cooks
or great recipes in our family?
And I think that's
kind of true for me.
I mean, that chess tarts
recipe that was one
of my absolute favorites
is Betty Crocker.
My mom may have put
her own twist on it,
but it started with Betty Crocker.
And that's okay.
Not everybody has the Italian
grandmother who knows how
to do things from the old country.
You take what you have
and you play with it
and you make it into
something special.
But it's still grounded
in those original roots.
One of the things that -- I worked
with my great-great-grandmother's
teacake recipe a lot,
and when I first made it, my
family didn't like it very much.
They're a very crisp cookie
and there's no extract
and they basically -- they're
very shortbread-like in a way.
You just taste the flour and
it was made with shortening.
So it didn't even have that
buttery taste like shortbread.
So I played with it a bit.
I took out a little
bit of the flour.
I reduced the baking time and the
baking temperature a little bit
until we got this wonderful
cookie that -- with the --
a little bit of lemon
or orange extract.
They're mild and they hold
their shape wonderfully.
So when you make them with those
-- these intricate cookie-cutters,
you don't have to chill the dough.
You just do it.
And that recipe is in
the book, by the way.
So it's become a favorite
recipe because I played with it.
And by the way, I included
this photograph.
I love this cookie-cutter
because of the button shape
and so I ordered them online.
And when they arrived I realized
that they had been
printed on a 3D printer.
And I thought, this
great-great-grandmother,
who was born in 1830, could she
have ever pictured, number one,
this PowerPoint slide with
the picture of her dough,
but this cookie-cutter that was made
on somebody's home
computer and printed 3D?
So sometimes I think that these
recipes, they can travel a long way,
and they're very flexible and
can do a lot of different things.
Another roadblock I hear
often is either I don't cook
or I don't cook anymore, so I
don't have anything to offer.
And I would say that
capture the whole foodways
of your family, not just recipes.
If you don't have a lot of
recipes or there's just a few,
you can still write about the
things that you are for holidays.
My uncle used to always take
us out for blueberry donuts
and whenever I eat a
blueberry donut I think
of my uncle even though I
don't think he's ever baked
or cooked a thing in his life.
But in my family cookbook I found
a great recipe for blueberry donuts
and I credited where it came from,
but that it was in his honor.
And it has a place in
the family cookbook.
So those family foodways, if
you don't have enough recipes,
you can kind of bring in surrogates.
Don't try to pass them off as
uncle's, you know, blueberry donuts.
But you can do things in honor.
Add supplementary materials.
So stories and photographs and
things to add to those recipes.
They mean so much more
than just this little bit
of writing on a card.
And then there are lots of ways --
if you're going to go about
collecting recipes, to work either
by yourself or to work with family.
And my experience is working
here with the Cookbook Committee
for the Bicentennial Cookbook
, are mentioned in my book.
I learned a lot about working as a
group on recipes and testing them
and how that can be very beneficial.
Another roadblock I hear is getting
recipes together is too hard.
My recipe stash is a mess.
And a lot of the people I
interviewed, they would, you know,
hold out these little
stacks, so they'd be digging
out of the junk drawer
and behind the microwave.
It's a challenge to organize
recipes and -- but as an archivist,
and many of us here are archivists,
organizing papers is our job.
So I gave some hints and clues on
how to go about getting organized.
Also how to identify which
recipes are heirloom.
When I looked at things from
my grandmother's generations,
they each left me a small handful.
So I saved everything
that they passed on.
But my mom had a lot of
recipes and whoa be, you know,
what I leave to my son because
I have shelves and shelves
of cookbooks and stacks
and stacks of recipes.
So how you sort of
go about identifying
which ones are really heirloom
recipes you want to pass on.
And then what's near
and dear to my heart
in this book is I put my
best archivist tips on how
to make sure those materials last
as long as possible because a lot
of people want to save those
things but don't know how to go
about properly housing them and
what to do to make sure they last.
So that information is there.
Another roadblock.
The recipes just don't work for
me the way they did for Grandma.
And that was one of my biggest
challenges because I'm not a cook
or a chef in a classic sense.
I was never trained.
But I had to learn.
You can clarify a recipe by
adding a little more information,
making sure you know exactly how
much liquid to put in the pot
or clarifying at what point
you slide it into the oven.
But then sometimes
you modify a recipe
like I did with the teacake recipe.
I have the original version
just as it was worded.
But I also have my version.
So if my son wants to make the
Christmas cookies he always
remember, that he knows
how I modified it.
So how to research
and adjust a recipe.
I tried to leave a trail of
information that I discovered.
I also did some appendices to
kind of give learn-by-example.
So I looked at biscuits and how it's
a -- you know, biscuits are simple.
There are just a few ingredients.
But there's a lot of
ways to adjust them,
whether you want them taller
or fluffier or whatever.
So I have an appendix where I
looked in depth at biscuits.
So if you're into biscuit-making
it is the cheat sheet.
You can find a way to
make your perfect biscuit
through that appendix.
And it's sort of an example of how
you would do that with other foods.
I also put in information about --
for many of us, if we go very
far back, suddenly we're working
with recipes from another time
or place, another culture.
So I had to go about that --
the finding ingredients and
translating and converting.
But sometimes it's just
a matter of region.
When I lived in Berkeley,
the trouble I had finding a decent
bag of grits was incredible.
So how you go about finding,
you know, the ingredients
that you really need to
make a recipe happen.
Another roadblock is the books
in my family don't use recipes,
so there's nothing to share.
And that was a tough one with me.
A lot of my Arkansas relatives, they
didn't have anything written down.
I've taught at oral history
workshops so I put in a lot
of the information
that I had from there.
But I learned a lot of tricks.
One of the things that I realized
early-on is that if you stop them
to try to make them
measure something,
it's [inaudible] screws them up.
They can't continue
their cooking process.
So I figured out to
get an electronic scale
and weigh everything
and then let them cook
and then you weigh it
again and do a subtraction,
you know how much they used.
That was a big breakthrough for me.
There were several recipes
that, once I figured that out,
it suddenly came clear
and were usable.
So how to interview people,
how to do an interview plan,
some sample questions on what
to ask, and I also developed,
with the help of a couple of fellow
cooks, a kind of a checklist.
If you have a complicated
recipe that's just not working,
how you go about sort of
narrowing it down to figure
out where the problem spot is in it.
I'm too late.
All the good family cooks are gone.
And that's one I've heard a lot.
I put in how to research things.
How to go -- these community
cookbooks are a goldmine.
And a lot of times
people have written things
down that you didn't even
know that they had written.
They've written them
for other people.
These great old family cooks, a
lot of times they didn't write
down a recipe because
they knew it by heart.
They didn't need to
have it written down.
But sometimes they would
write it down for a new bride
or someone leaving home
for the first time.
And by knowing ways to track
it down, sometimes you discover
that those recipes that you
thought were unwritten got written
down at some point
if you can find them.
I also did some appendices that
help with that, with biscuits.
I researched sort of the origins
of biscuits and how they came about
and the ingredients that needed
to come together to develop,
to make those kind of fluffy
baking powder biscuits.
And then when I was
growing up our --
my next door neighbor
was a fantastic cook.
She was Cajun and she
was going to --
she talked often about how she going
to write a cookbook
when she retired.
And then died of cancer,
and never got there.
So I interviewed her husband and
her three sons, trying to figure
out if someone's gone, how do
you pull out some of that legacy?
How do you make sure that
-- you can't save it all.
But how do you make sure
that something is carried
forward to the next generation?
And I learned a lot
about doing that.
I don't have time for a big
project is another one I heard.
So there's one chapter about
sort of different ideas.
I interviewed a family that they're
scattered across the United States
and then as far as Saudi, Arabia.
And they have a cooking blog
where they all have the password
and so they post and they
post pictures and comments
and then periodically
they print it all out.
And it's their way of
this scattered family
of sharing these family foodways.
So there are a lot of neat
ideas now that are out there.
And then I brought
show show and tell.
It never has to be too elaborate.
Here's a little cookbook
that somebody made.
They just typed out the recipes,
sewed it with a sewing machine
to make the binding,
and then cut up a piece
of a Christmas card for the cover.
Simple, but a goldmine.
Here's another one that
somebody did the same thing.
This one, thankfully, they added
a few sentences about the recipe
which I think is really important.
And they just punched a hole
in the side, added a ribbon,
and gave it to everybody
for Christmas.
Here is one -- this is a woman,
that she did this one with --
she had lots of recipes and
then she put it together
with her favorite quotations
to inspire her grandchildren --
family stories, took it
to the office supply place
and had them put a
spiral binding on it.
It's not fancy, it's not
expensive, but it's very effective.
Then this is my favorite
way to do gift ones.
I think -- like Snapfish
and Shutterfly, Walgreens,
there's lots of places
that do these photo books.
And by -- you can type out recipes
and print them and turn them
into JPEGs with a scanner.
Or you can just scan
the original recipe
so you see the handwriting
and all that.
Oops, I'm sorry.
By doing it this way, you
can sort of share copies
of all these family recipes
sort of in all their glory along
with the photographs and the life
dates and those sorts of things.
These things, they live on the
server of the photo company
that you're, you know,
working with their software.
So what I do is I make them
and then I let them sit there,
and when I know another
gift occasion
like somebody else is
getting married in the family,
you can do a Save As on that
website and design, you know,
like a frontpage for that specific
person and then print it out,
you know, a new copy
for that new person.
They also do a lot of sales,
so if I do something like this,
I'll get it done as early as I can
and then every week
I check the coupons,
and when they hit the three-for-one
sale, bing, I order everything
for Christmas in one fell swoop.
And then the last thing I
want to share with you --
this is the cookbook
I made for my son.
We love to cook together and we were
always sort of missing peach season.
We'd come and go and we'd
forget to do the peach recipes.
So we put it together
in chronological order
and it's all the recipes.
I had typed them up so I
printed them out on pretty paper
because it makes it more
interesting for a seven-year-old.
I did some little photo collages,
again just at the drugstore,
printed them out, of pictures
of things we cooked and pictures
of the two of us cooking together.
But also pictures of the people
where the recipes came from.
So my son, even though he's seven,
he knows the names of his --
the grandparents he never got to
meet, and knows what they look like.
He knows what his great
grandparents' names are
and what they look like.
He's connected to it and he
knows a lot of the special things
that we've done and where
they've come from over the years.
And we have a lot of fun
pulling out those same things
at the same time every year.
It's a easy way to do it.
I can wipe off if there's
spatters because they're
in those little plastic sleeves.
And if it ever, you know,
falls into the fire I can print
out another copy which
is always good to know.
It can't get lost at time.
The last roadblock
I'd say is people --
I've heard often said that
nobody is interested but me.
And I put this as the last one
because it sort of
comes back on you.
I think to teach your children,
your nieces, your nephews,
but also the people that are
on the same generation as you.
The more you talk about food, the
more you talk about family history,
the more they start to
feel interested in it.
And even if they feign
indifference now,
or maybe they are indifferent
now, but as time goes
on they may become interested.
I think -- one of the
things I've seen is a lot
of times people get interested
at about retirement age,
so right about the time that the
generation before them has all
died out.
They suddenly think,
I didn't think to ask.
Well, if you save these things,
then the people who come behind you,
if they didn't think
to ask early enough,
you've been kind enough
to save things for them.
The last thing I would say is
that sometimes you think
there's not a lot out there.
When I started this book
I had two recipes from one
of my great grandmothers.
And by learning how to do the
research and learning who to ask
and learning some of
the tricks, I now --
this recipe that's pictured here is
for uncooked peanut butter fudge.
My aunt sent it to me.
I did ask her several
times about family recipes
and she told me, oh,
I don't have any.
When my book came out and I
sent her a copy of the book,
the next week I got
this in the mail.
She said, I knew you wanted recipes.
I knew I had this.
But I just didn't connect
it in my head.
And once I -- she finally
did and sent this.
Now I have recipes from all
four of my great-grandmothers
which I would have
thought was impossible
because they didn't live
for me to meet them.
But sometimes it is
possible, which is fantastic.
That was kind of fast.
So are there any questions
or comments?
Lots of those people like to tell
me stories which I love, too.
Yeah.
>> If you're living
[inaudible] a little bit.
If you get a recipe
that [inaudible].
I got two -- not so
much the food itself,
but the memory that was [inaudible].
This is [inaudible] when I was
around 11 years old, we were living
at my grandmother's
house [inaudible],
and she was making cookies, and
I used to sneak in the middle
of the night, take two
cookies, bring them to my bed,
and I couldn't get up in
the morning [inaudible].
It was the memory of
an idea [inaudible].
But that's an item
itself, but what it evokes.
>> Valerie Frey: It's true.
What he said is it's
not the item itself.
It's what it evokes.
And I think that can be true.
One of the things that several
people I interviewed mentioned was
that not knowing when they
finally found a recipe and made it,
is this really what it tasted like?
Sometimes it's disappointing
like this isn't good.
I think the memory of it
is probably everything.
You know, if you -- you know, if
you make something and it's not,
it doesn't taste as
good as it used to.
The memory is still very
important and compelling.
One of the most interesting essays
I've read about the concept was
in the Cornbread Nation which
is a collection of food-writings,
and they've done several.
And I think it was
Cornbread Nation Four .
It was a essay about the -- there
was a lull after Hurricane Katrina,
and then all of a sudden the recipe
boards on various websites were hit
and hit hard with people desperate
to find copies or surrogates
of recipes as a birthday came around
and you're living in a FEMA trailer.
But if you can make the
cake that tastes like home,
we would all feel better.
And people trying to find those
recipes and track them down again.
There is real meaning, emotional
meaning, behind those recipes,
like with our chess tarts.
You know, to take a bite.
It means something to me that that
recipe is there and I've been able
to make it the way it tastes.
And it means something
to my brother.
It does.
>> Judith Jones, who
edited Julia Childs,
always invited the [inaudible].
She did many cookbooks.
But she invited the authors to
cook in her penthouse apartment
which had a kitchen
the size of a closet.
But she has Lidia Bas Tianich
and she was observing her.
And she saw her make a dry spot
in the middle of the frying pan
and squirting in some tomato paste.
And so she said to Lidia,
"Lidia, whatever are you doing?"
And said, "Well," she said,
"I always toast the tomato
paste before I stir it
in because it gives me an
extra layer of flavor."
And Judith put her hands upon her
shoulders and said, [inaudible] that
and worse, you're going to
tell your readers this?"
And Lidia said, "I didn't know
I did it, you know [laughter]."
And --
>> Valerie Frey: Yeah.
>> -- and that was the very
reason that Judith had her do it,
because she knew that if she watched
the cook that she would catch up.
That's some of these little
things that make a difference.
>> Valerie Frey: Yeah.
The kitchen visit can
make all the difference.
This, you know, recipe for
mulligan that my grandfather sent,
he thought he had sent
the complete recipe.
There were so many things he did
without even thinking about it.
It made a difference in the flavor.
So being able to watch
sometimes is really key.
Yeah.
>> My mother was a very good cook.
And my best friend really liked
this [inaudible] made from pork.
So she asked her for the recipe.
And she said, I don't have a recipe.
Well, please give me the recipe.
So she finally, you
know, said, [inaudible].
But she cooked it and
it tasted [inaudible].
And the thing is, what
my mother did,
she put all what she
said in her cooking.
But then she changed it.
And then, oh, it's not enough
salt, so she added salt.
There's not enough
sugar so she added it.
So the adding stuff is not included.
That's why it tastes different.
>> Valerie Frey: It's true.
And I think a lot of times
what I discovered was --
like my grandpa, he couldn't
tell you exactly what to do
with the tomatoes because it
depends on how juicy the tomatoes
or acidic the tomatoes, you know.
Have we had much rain lately?
How were the tomatoes
turning out this year?
But the more I cooked with him,
I got him in the habit of talking
out loud to me of -- he
would say, taste this.
It has that taste.
And I would suddenly realize
that, okay, it's a little acidic.
That's what we're dealing with here.
It's not an exact science.
And there's no way to -- for me
to promise you that if you go
through these five steps you will
get a successful recipe at the end.
But I think one of the things
I learned is that when you work
with another cook, it develops
a really beautiful relationship
as the two of you as sort of
co-artists work together and learn
to talk together and
learn to really look
and watch what each
other's doing to get close.
And then to -- you know, in the
end, a lot of times you have
to have your own way of doing it.
It may not taste exactly
like grandma's.
But you've gotten close and maybe if
she's still here you've spent time
with her and really sort
of gotten into her head
of how she makes her
cooking decisions.
Not exact science, but a
beautiful thing when you're talking
about connections and
foodways and why it matters.
You know, working with those
cooks is one of the best,
best time you'll ever spend.
>> Valerie, thank you
for being an inspiration.
I can actually --
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
I'm a social entrepreneur.
Kind of work my [inaudible].
>> Valerie Frey: Oh.
>> I also did a lot of [inaudible].
So I've been to Greece
a couple of times
when the [inaudible] first come in.
There's a restaurant called
Damas, short of Damascus.
And it's fascinating.
So [inaudible] the first thing
you lose is your language
when you go to a new land.
Then some of your customs.
The last of your connections
with food.
So it's interesting.
It's fascinating to have people
leave Syria, go across to Turkey,
and take this really biggest
journey across the Aegean.
And they come to Greece.
Their native food in this
restaurant [inaudible].
So I'm not [inaudible] going back
to [inaudible] and their recipes.
So this is very important
to me [inaudible].
>> Valerie Frey: Oh, thank you.
That's really, really important.
Yeah. To be a stranger
in a strange land.
I've only tasted, you
know, that by, you know,
leaving when I was pregnant
and having a baby somewhere
thousands of miles away.
It still is nothing compared
to what they're dealing with.
And the challenges of
finding the recipes
that work and the ingredients.
So, I hope that goes very well.
>> Thanks.
>> Valerie Frey: Yeah.
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
>> -- my grandmother [inaudible]
the first step [inaudible] from her.
But when I made it, it
just didn't [inaudible] --
>> Valerie Frey: Right.
>> -- right.
And that really [inaudible]
in the kitchen with her.
And then realizing that
she left out something.
>> Valerie Frey: Yeah [laughter].
>> Because it's like, oh,
well, writing it down.
I'll make sure I do this.
And she didn't write it all down.
So really having that connection
and being able to work [inaudible].
>> Valerie Frey: Yeah.
>> [Inaudible] really.
>> Yeah. Oh, I forgot
to add this, you know.
And even if you get the same recipe.
For instance, you cook a
recipe and I cook a recipe,
and we did exactly
what they tell you,
it's still comes up [inaudible].
>> Valerie Frey: It can.
>> And because I think our
taste buds are different.
And I also know this, you
know, like I'm buying food
for different -- from
different people.
So I [inaudible].
So I have two friends
[inaudible] and from one friend,
whatever she cooks, I like it.
And the other, you
know, I [inaudible].
So, first page, from
the one that I like,
is exactly like my [inaudible].
That's why I like all --
whatever she cooks I like it.
>> Valerie Frey: Right.
It's true.
I mean it's a fascinating thought
that people who are good cooks,
that they -- without being able
to articulate it, there's a range
of flavors and techniques that
they've adopted that's sort of --
that person in cooking form,
which is -- it's fascinating.
And when you've lost that --
that appendix that I wrote
about the Cajun chef,
I think her sons have kind
of -- you struggle with that.
But after a while, at
least to be inspired
and learn to cook your own way.
But it's still grounded in those
roots because you've taken the time
to collect those recipes and learn
from that way of doing things.
It's fascinating.
>> Yeah, it's very personal.
>> Valerie Frey: It
is very personal.
Yeah.
>> I've been lucky
enough to be in a family
of pretty good [inaudible]
all the time.
However, my grandmother, who
would [inaudible] was apparently a
terrible cook.
My mother and my aunt
have no interest in --
I know that you've kind of talked
about this already, but you know,
they feel very above all of the
stuff that their mother made.
What advice do you have for me
to kind of spark their interest
and say, hey, I know that, you
know, you can doctor this up
and make it better,
but how can I get --
convince them that
it's worth it, I guess.
>> Valerie Frey: Yeah.
Well, apparently a lot of sources
-- there's a lot of cookbooks
and websites and blogs
that are very interested
in the mid-century cooking.
And if that's what they're sort
of dealing with, is opening a can
of this, opening a mix of that --
Julia Child called them
assemblies, not recipes.
But they do have value.
I mean, one of my favorite things --
my mom would open cans of cherry
pie filling and then you --
I'm sure some of you
are nodding this.
You dump cake mix over
it, and then some butter.
It's called a dump cake.
And it's fantastic [laughter].
It's really low-brow
and it's fantastic.
I guess to -- if you can show
them some of those cookbooks.
You know, go to the library
and see if you can grab some
of those mid-century celebration
kind of cookbooks and show them
that there are people who
are interested in this
and there are people who love this.
And that you would really
like to know the way,
you know, that those were done.
And it's true that -- I've developed
a mushroom sauce that's the right --
it's the right proportion, so
you can use it instead of any
of those cream of mushroom soup.
And you can do things like that.
And if you let them know that, hey,
this is the trail I want to follow,
but I want to stay
grounded in these roots.
I hope that they'll
listen and [laughter] --
that's kind of difficult.
But I hope so.
Yeah.
>> Sort of picking up
on that [inaudible].
It seems to me that holidays,
whatever your family
holiday traditions are,
is that it has to be a prime place.
Because, you know, your chess
tarts or grandma's sugar cookies
or whatever your family tradition
is, even if it wasn't great,
there has to be pretty solid
memories, right [laughter]?
So that would be a
pretty good [inaudible] --
>> Valerie Frey: Yeah.
>> -- to talk about where that
came from or where your --
what their parents
did [inaudible], too.
I mean [laughter].
>> Valerie Frey: That's true.
And so if you go far enough back you
hit the fresh and local thing again.
You know, my great grandparents --
that was the only way they
cooked was fresh and local
and you could say, hey, there's
a lot of interest in that now.
I want to learn how to do it.
Yeah.
>> Will you be at the Smithsonian's
Food [inaudible] Festival
this Saturday?
>> Valerie Frey: No.
I wish I could.
My husband was a VMI graduate and
their reunion is this weekend.
But I would love to.
Yeah.
>> So one of the pushbacks
that I got as I try
to show value [inaudible]
cookbooks, is, well,
I can get a recipe off Google.
And, you know, I try to say, well,
how about [inaudible] in memories
and -- what do you usually -- how do
you stop and see that [inaudible]?
>> Valerie Frey: I don't know.
I mean there's some times like,
you know, trying to teach somebody
to love history or teach them
to love their family history.
It can be a long road.
But sometimes it can always
again turn on a dime, you know,
to get them to understand
that the recipes
that they have are very specific.
They were chosen -- brought into
the family for various reasons.
And they really reflect that family.
And it's sort of a
unique conglomeration
that will never ever come
again, that collection.
So that's probably the
way I would approach it,
is even if they're not the most
unique recipes in the world,
it's a unique collection.
And I guess we're getting
sort of short on time.
Let me take one more
question though.
>> When you did your cookbook,
and there was a relative
who had not given you a recipe,
do you think sometimes they're --
well, I'm not going to
give that one recipe.
You know, that's my recipe.
>> Valerie Frey: Yeah.
>> And any suggestions
that you would have --
I think producing the
cookbook, that's a good thing
because they under -- they see it.
But yet that recipe was
contained in it [inaudible].
You understand what I'm saying.
>> Valerie Frey: Yes.
That was a problem I came
across over and over again.
And I did, I did talk
about it in the book.
That a lot of times it's
a quality control issue.
This is my pet recipe and what if
you don't do a good job with it
and then you say it's mine?
So a lot of times when I --
when someone is kind enough to
give me a real signature recipe,
I assure them that I will
take great pains with it.
Also a lot of times, people
really want to be credited
for that something special
that they've developed.
And so I will tell them, this
will have your name in the title.
And I will not change
anything about it.
And sometimes that puts
people's fears to rest.
But I came across so
many stories about that.
And what I recommended is
if they just can't stand
to not have the corner on the
market, have them write it
down in detail as best they can
and put it with their last will
and testament [laughter].
That's the -- sort
of they can have it.
But one of the things that
I pointed out to them --
if you hold that recipe
forever and you die with it,
people will talk longingly about
it for, oh, a decade, maybe two,
and then you vanish into the ether.
But if you've saved that
recipe and you've shared it,
and you've taken pains with it,
you'll become legendary [laughter].
>> Yeah, thanks.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.